SpaceX is the new kid on the block born
in 2002 from PayPal billionaire Elon
Musk
his company set out with a lofty mission
to colonize Mars you ever question if
you're crazy
yes I think it's important to question
your sanity because at the point which
you stop questioning your sanity you're
probably insane the end of NASA's
shuttle program left the world with only
one way to get to the International
Space Station Russia we're supposed to
pay over seventy million dollars per
seat to the Russians just to go to the
Space Station it's just kind of
embarrassing that the United States has
to thumb rides from the Russians a new
shuttle will soon take flight but NASA
won't be making it they have become the
client instead of the boss with private
enterprise assuming the majority of the
physical and financial risk Elon Musk
has sunk 100 million dollars of his own
fortune into SpaceX SpaceX's dragon is a
capsule design meant to hold both crew
and cargo and can stay in orbit for up
to two years
how much cheaper is it going to be to
send an astronaut to the International
Space Station using dragon dragon can
take up to seven people and if nASA uses
the full complement of crew and orders
for per year we can do it for twenty
million dollars person
what is unique about the drag we went
out and looked at you know all the
electronic revolution that's been going
on over the last 10 20 30 years and and
looked up the very best that's out there
and say how do we apply that to space
we're looking at a dragon right now yeah
come on up I don't think it's that
substantially more expensive to apply
crew actually because for cargo you have
a lot of requirements on how you treat
that cargo we have to provide power and
data to all the cargo items so a lot of
that core functionality remains the same
rocket and dragon the SpaceX Dragon
capsule is launched into space by the
company's own rocket called Falcon 9
dragon is the first commercial
spacecraft in history to deliver cargo
to the International Space Station and
safely return to Earth a mission
previously achieved by only three
nations this is the first Dragon
spacecraft you can see the the heat
shield and the scorch marks this payment
like a flaming meteor how did it feel
when I came back in one piece [ __ ] right
it's like wow I can't believe it work
we're kind of like a Silicon Valley
technology company that's doing space
what qualifies you to put human beings
every launch of the Falcon 9 rocket
switch is the rocket that would carry
astronauts has succeeded so it's got a
hundred percent success rate which is I
mean the best success rate of any rocket
ever